[Musica]
prendiamo oggi di democrazia digitale è
certamente la prima cosa da osservare
che democrazia non significa
semplicemente garantire il voto tutti
garantire a tutti i diritti politici e
civili democrazia prima di tutto e dare
a tutti la possibilità di capire e di
comprendere senza cultura cioè la
democrazia è una forma vuota perché le
persone non hanno la possibilità di
esercitare la non hanno gli strumenti
per esercitarla non hanno gli strumenti
per decidere e per scegliere
certo possono votare ma è un voto per
così dire inconsapevole
ecco perché internet può diventare uno
strumento fondamentale per la democrazia
al di là del fatto che possa aiutarlo
non aiutare il voto diretto ma proprio
per come strumento per garantire la
comprensione e la diffusione della
cultura già dante nel convivio si poneva
questo problema quando sembrava che il
compito degli intellettuali era non solo
sapere ma comunicare il sapere e cioè
non tenere il sapere paese come
strumento di potere e di ricchezza e
questo è un aspetto rivoluzionario è
fondamentale la base stessa dell'idea e
dell'abbandono del latino e l'idea era
quella dunque del convivio il convivio e
il tavolo imbandito attorno al quale si
siedono molto invitati la cultura doveva
diventare appunto un convivio doveva
diventare qualcosa che si metteva in
comune la cultura come il pane tutti ne
avevano bisogno
tutti dovevano avere una parte tutti
dovevano poterla come dire consumare
dovevano poter
assaggiare e proprio su dante cogliendo
lo spunto del settecentesimo
anniversario della sua morte abbiamo
dedicato non a caso una stanza nel
nostro nuovo progetto digitale istanze
italiana.it
ma cosa diremmo se il tavolo cui siamo
invitati questo convivio ideale qui
siamo invitati per la diffusione della
cultura si trovasse in un terribile
disordine cosa diremmo se nello stesso
piatto trovassimo che ne so il gelato è
la trippa il dolce è mescolato con
salato diremmo che è un tavolo imbandito
ma le diremo che quel convivio è un gran
bivio inavvicinabile e che quel pranzo
quel pane è immangiabile
ecco è quello che rischia di succedere
di accadere con internet in internet i
contenuti i linguaggi che sono
moltissimi rischiano però di
intrecciarsi e di confonde e si creando
in un certo senso una specie di
pulviscolo che ci cattura col suo
scintillio map sono pre brevi momenti
senza lasciarci nulla realmente di
solido
ecco non basta dunque promuovere la
cultura con internet bisogna farlo dando
un ordine bisogna cioè concepire
internet come uno spazio che va ordinato
esattamente come lo spazio reale quando
costruiamo un museo quando costruiamo un
auditorium quando progettiamo anche un
giardino
ecco e gli italiani sono sempre stati
grandi organizzatori di spazi ancora
oggi se in ios ci si muove in alcune
parti della penisola si vedono queste
magnifici questi magnifici quadrati da
centuriazione romana il segno della
civiltà era prima di tutto la geometria
con cui si disegnava lo spazio e questa
capacità di disegnare lo spazio in modo
unitario e caratteristica di tutta la
nostra civiltà la magia delle nostre
città non sta nella bellezza di un
singolo edificio
ma prima di tutto nel rapporto che lega
un edificio all'altro la continuità dei
portici la continuità dei cornicioni
il modo in cui uno stile lo stile di un
edificio dialoga con quello degli
edifici vicini insomma l'organizzazione
dello spazio trasforma ogni parte di
quello spazio ogni edificio in una
parola collegata alle altre in un solo
discorso
ecco che l'immagine della città ideale
con cui noi accogliamo il visitatore
nelle nostre stanze italiane è metafora
non solo di un'architettura ma di un
ordine che rappresenta l'ordine della
cultura è anche un ordine civile
internet
insomma non deve essere solo per
svolgere davvero le funzioni di uno
strumento democratico non deve essere
solo un magazzino di contenuti ma deve
diventare una specie di città ideale
attraverso un nuovo linguaggio che
dobbiamo plasmare con le stesse esigenze
di armonia di misura di chiarezza che
hanno ispiegato le costruzioni delle
nostre città reali la democrazia
digitale deve permettere a tutti in
italia nel mondo di praticare lo stato
italiano appunto inteso non solo come
tesori di contenuti ma come esperienza
di forum
ecco perché abbiamo pensato di creare a
new york che per così dire la città
ideale del nuovo mondo un edificio di
cultura virtuale accanto all'edificio
dell'istituto di cultura reale le stanze
italiane che rendano umano abitabile
suggestivo e invitante lo spazio di
internet stanza tra l'altro nella nostra
lingua non è solamente uno spazio reale
cioè la camera ma è anche la strofa sia
in poesia sia in musica e cioè il modo
in cui vengono ordinate organizzate le
parole ei suoni in questo modo
l'incontro con la cultura non è un
affannoso inciampa che tra i detriti
diciamo così di un magazzino ma è un
viaggio e in questo modo accanto a nuove
forme di integrazione possiamo offrire
diciamo possiamo legare i singoli eventi
per esempio un concerto al contesto che
li spiega democrazia digitale è anche la
possibilità di guidare chi entra nello
spazio di internet alla comprensione non
solo
all'incontro con un evento ma la
comprensione al senso di quell'evento
e allora ecco che per esempio un
concerto si unirà alla lezione di uno
storico all'intervista ai musicisti a
tutte le cose che servono per
comprendere per aiutare a comprendere
quella musica un primo orientamento ha
proposto tramite la piattaforma delle
stanze italiane organizza dunque le
attività del nostro edificio secondo la
struttura della casa e quindi l'atrio in
cui si comprende come la casa è
strutturata e la sua storia la galleria
in cui si troveranno tutte le forme in
cui la cultura italiana e la cultura
americana dialogano tre di loro il lesto
a soprattutto e cioè il portico che è
caratteristico delle nostre città
italiane che un luogo coperto ma aperto
insieme luogo della mobilità il luogo
dell'incontro
il luogo del dialogo ecco è così come
tante altre stanze del cine score
dedicato ai bambini
gli orti dedicati all'estetica
della natura alla costruzione del
paesaggio il caminetto in cui
testimonianze di relazioni di rapporti
di vita che legano degli stati uniti e
l'italia verranno raccontate e
svolgeranno anche una funzione di
mentoring internet tra l'altro e
concludo così offre la posta ordinaria
possibilità di trasformare ogni testo in
un ipertesto cioè di aprire ogni testo a
finestre interpretative e conoscitive
che lo pongono in relazione non solo con
altri testi ma con altri linguaggi il
cinema con la musica la rete con la
storia non so la pittura con la
religione o conoscenza anche in questo
senso della democrazia digitale non è
solo partecipazione alla cultura ma
esperienza di questo carattere sistemico
organico per cui ogni testo si collega
un discorso più ampio
ogni testo ha bisogno di un discorso
interdisciplinare per comprenderlo e
questo è un altro aspetto fondamentale
della civiltà italiana questo carattere
organico e sistemico che troviamo sia
nei singoli e penso a figure come
leonardo come michelangelo fino a
pasolini sia nei movimenti dal
rinascimento al futurismo i movimenti
italiani di solito toccano ogni aspetto
della vita e della cultura
e per concludere direi allora che
dobbiamo concepire internet seguendo
l'insegnamento notissimo di mcluhan per
cui il mezzo influenza e in un certo
senso determina il messaggio cioè
dobbiamo
usare internet non solo come deposito di
dati da divulgare e proprio in questa
visione di democrazia digitale ma
dobbiamo usarlo per renderlo democratico
come linguaggio che va elaborato che va
costruito che va ordinato e dobbiamo
farlo e possiamo farlo perché noi
italiani abbiamo per secoli imparato e
insegnato anche a costruire linguaggi al
mondo ogni linguaggio e la nostra casa e
noi come un grande filosofo del secolo
scorso ha detto siamo i suoi custodi
anche di internet